Mr Mayor I'm going to hand over to you
oh thank you just for those who weren't
at the um the risk and Assurance I'm
eating this morning this is just a
duplication of that so we're just
formally adopting the
annual report a bit of a backdrop to it
um reasonably tense meeting this morning
for those that were there they'll recall
that
um and that was predominantly around
um our view that the previous order
um was not satisfactory and it's timing
and secondly it was worse than the
previous year to that which was uh not
good either so we saw a bit of a
slippery slide
um uh since the meeting this morning
there's been some
backwards and forwards meetings with um
all in New Zealand and the chief
executive who was down today for our
meeting
to try and defuse the situation because
my initial position was that I would not
sign the
annual audit report that has to go away
and that would trigger a whole tsunami
of issues including a report from the
orders agenda to Parliament
um and so we worked our way through that
but having said that we the legal
requirement for a
an annual report it's the 31st of
October we extended it out till the 20th
of December as our Benchmark we wouldn't
go any further and here we are on the
7th of March just doing it now so not a
good experience for the last 12 months
and to be taking that many months
um it's not good so they've um they've
agreed to uh do better next year and the
players involved give me some insurance
and Michael and Patricia were there and
so their confidence so that's a good
thing I stressed to order New Zealand
that we cannot afford to lose key staff
over our
joint ability to do audits in a timely
manner or to do them in a way that
doesn't frustrate the hell out of both
parties
um you know I just said to them look you
know there are some jobs in this Council
that you you die in a ditch to retain uh
Financial Auditors are one building
inspectors
um
I.T people
um people like that you just need to
have them can't afford losing their
precious
so we've got some uh some generations of
that and uh it's um some commitment from
audit New Zealand that they would do
significantly better next year the
consequences of not signing would have
been that the order of Jenna would then
have not accepted our audit report and
it would have gone to Parliament that
would have upset potentially um our
borrowers in the marketplace you might
have thought that there was stuff to be
concerned about and I would have a
trickle-down effect as well so
I've bit my lip and taking the street
away but we don't want to tell Bruce too
early because we want him to sweat a
little bit
um but yeah it's turned out to be okay
but the uh it's not been a good
experience for the staff that it had to
um I guess do this remotely and so a lot
of the questions have come from not a
personal visit or an annual plan about
how they're going to resolve it the
audit is just constant telephone calls
saying we want more information clarify
this clarify there and the staff have
just got to the end of their dealer so
fingers crossed to take next year
um
so we've got a set of recommendations
for that report
as you see and I know you've all read
the 252 page report so I'm really
pleased about that just one Amendment
for the record at the top has got
approved by Michael Day acting chief
executive that's no longer
a current title current title drops the
acting so Michael has been appointed on
the 26th of last month
so it's quite a long report and if
people want to raise any questions I
guess now is the time before I put a
whole series of uh recommendations that
go with it
then
Bruce is about to join yeah
I don't want to tell him too early that
he's
he's not to worry about this
so no questions on that
are we waiting to get Bruce are we
no we're not
no okay well there's no questions on it
and it is a very detailed report but it
has been worked through by staffer and
certainly by the uh risk and Assurance
committee this morning we've had
Ross behind me involved as well so we
worked away quite nicely so I've got
real confidence that it's okay
what we're putting up yeah putting aside
the fact that it's taking way too long
so something you'd like to move all
those recommendations that would be
great
thank you Leslie
oh yes Darren yes excellent
the team again any discussion about
those recommendations
there being none I'll just put those in
all those in favor done
and you can rush you can tell Bruce that
I will sign the papers later today so
you can sleep all right tonight
thank you and I'll be appreciate that
yeah yeah I was trying to hold out as
long as I could
uh look in on the
um uh look knobby without wanting to
prolong your meeting
um you're aware of the discussions we
have had and they have been substantive
and substantial with audit New Zealand
was it was good to record a note that
Stephen Walker the executive director
was here so
um yes we want change and and I think
your tactics have helped get that thank
you Navi
okay
thank you
so if somebody would have liked to close
that part of the meeting
oh sorry no
you know
so Tab four we've done that you've done
that
oh yes
for Michael Morris Wherever You Are
over there
we've got a paper here from you on Major
League
recommendations to council from the
finance and project committee meeting
held 21st of February
and my clock is just bringing through
the recommendations from the Western
Assurance committee meeting of this
morning is the minutes aren't able to be
prepared in such a short time frame
whereas we can
oh sorry oh my apologies
keep thinking Michael no this is the
finance and projects committee this was
a recommendation that was unfortunately
missed being moved at the last um
council meeting and given that there was
an extraordinary meeting held today this
was an opportune time to get this
recommendation through from the
financing projects committee uh approved
by Council so apologies for this it was
an oversight win the edging during
minutes we're prepared for the council
meeting last week so I'll move that have
been received as a modulate item and
moved the recommendation yeah you think
you can think of your Grant senatorial
committee all those in favor carried
thank you Mr Mia somebody like to close
that down and go into PE for your
benefit okay I'm gonna just wait for the
live streaming to end